[Music]  look  we want to make a movie  this could become a cultural phenomenon  the likes we've never seen before well  then we better get started  i know how to make this film  it's a metaphor  for the american dream  this is not just some gangster film it  makes us look like a joke and that's bad  for business this is a story about  family  it's shakespeare  agencies won't touch us it's epic you  want to be crazy bang borrow still do  whatever it takes gangster movies are  dead we will snuff out the hatred i say  i'm gonna handle something good  you're still gonna try and make this  thing sinatra wants us to shut the  picture down you got brains and you got  balls  try using both  i can't lose this  what is our opening line  i believe in america  [Music]  [Music]  you